And the answer is that F = MA.
So, we have it. the equation of Newtonian physics.
Force times acceleration--what a beautiful equation.
It says that the cause of acceleration is force.
When I apply a force to a mass, I get acceleration.
This one equation when properly applied can be used to derive almost all of Newtonian physics.
So, congratulations.
Now that you have this equation, you're done. You might as well stop.
If you can do all these things, what's left to learn. See you in the next class, I guess.
But that's not entirely true,
because even though this equation is underlying all of these things,
we still need to know how to use it.